拆香来了 炸了半粿的快点
再不拆我们家的要成一占了
马上开始
这个是我为长班山准备的出片神气
蓝色的危机 蓝色的毛融手
它血白血白的帽子
我觉得这套真的是出乎一亮帽子
看起来质量 质感也挺好的
手套就更不用说了
服务一场非常可爱
是我在喊在那买了两件睡衣
这个精致远的那个桶款
我觉得这个粉色很好看
有一个红色的包边
就显得非常草习
它是一个睡袍
就是睡一曲
治感摸下也挺不错的
就是一套紫色的睡衣
然后是一个绿色的包边
也会显得人非常的火破草习
我们一起买衣服的份动线拆
这个是我在iCo直播间买的
这个版型还可以
但是我觉得我个人好像不太适合这种
非常非常的花的这种
这个也是在它直播间墙
这些也等了很久
这是一个大衣
就是我看iCo穿的好美好美
就忍不住相单了
它这个领子就是有一个那种
沟边的
这两件是我的伤场买个衣气
把它拆了看一下
这个是买一个
应该叫秋衣充裤板
非常非常的保暖
据说就是素干醒的
就是出了汉之后
它马上就可以干掉
这是买了一个蒙克里尔的
鱼融服
这是我第一次在他们家买鱼融
它这个Merry的话
就是这种比较修显一点的话
是就帽子可以取下来的
而这件是我觉得在蒙克里面
我是了那么多件之后
我觉得它上升是
我穿的最好看的
继续拆
它是一个真知的背心
我觉得单穿或者是
里面搭一个那种白色的铁水
然后外面穿一个这一个应该都
挺好看的
再来一个尔照
也是我为了长白山准备的
真的
质量很好耶
而且它才二十多块钱
就毛
摸起来很舒服
而且它不掉毛
忠于拆到它了
这个是我被腾结中草的
这一批拆下一个
我最期待的一东西
这种我知道是什么
是我在梁卡佛
他们家买的一件
Skings的
这个T-shirt
特别的显示我
然后穿的又很舒服
但是那种谈力很大的
我非常期待的一件与融服
它的领则是这种毛融感的
我觉得这件也还挺错的
这个应该也是他们家的一个
融服
它的这个里面是黑色的
然后外面是白色的
就是穿的时候会把里面的黑领
会露出来
这是我买的一顶
灰色的毛子
因为我发现我还买
是和灰色的
他们家的质量蛮好的
就跟小龙狗也还挺好看的
这是我看那个
雲灾
它有一次穿这件衣服
特别特地好看
然后我就买了它的统款
我记得好像这一套
它还有个外套
这一套特两半都快钱
但是说实话
我摸起来这个才
其实真的是挺差的
但是它的这个款是还是蛮好看的
这是我在麦卡什么
我今天里面买着一件打击
它是这种种种种的
这种开始很保暖的
基本上穿一个这个打击
外面在套个外套就可以了
这是我买的一个洋种的护子
这个护子
它雖然很臭
可是它穿上身真的挺有感觉的
这个的版型
真的非常非常的好很显手
而且那把屁股也保护得很好
这是我去年买的
没有这么起车
当然他们家都是持马要注意一点
我一米七二五十四公斤
我只要穿他们家的三差
但这个是我买的家种的位置
讲厚十一点的
这我买三个颜色
一个卡几色
还有一个是这种签灰色
它的这个面料的话会你那个洋洋的跟修显一些
还有一个这种好的方式
那种轻色还是黑色
我好像不是合穿这个很身边的作品
但现在这个是什么
这是我买的一个融库
马上我这个男方人叫去长班山
所以我买了一个这种
很厚的融库
不知道保暖性怎么样
穿了的话给你们分享
这个收卖的一个皮草
这丰卖了两件皮草
看一下怎么样
保卖吗
让看好像好像可以
开始品上的话我觉得好像挺好看的
好期待这一切
因为这一切我觉得
它上身特别好看很轻薄
我觉得上金的话看起来
这件比刚才那件
用融化贵一点
反而我觉得这个过年穿是可以的
这个日子过得非常的好
这一年相当的不错
这个应该是我买的挖子
我买了四双
就是羊毛挖买的
就是用我非常保暖的
那摸起来还可以
我的文一斤都一大碗
刚好刚刚才为了那个猫子
可以变成一套
它不到100块钱
但是我觉得它摸起来这个质感很好
啊这是一个手套
这个手套好沾它实验
而且它这个地方好可爱
这个小扣子就可以
玩手机方面很方便不错
质量很好
这个是不可可以的
我买的
有就是我干批朋友给我推荐的
顾原油能途上去之后
它虽然很认真突然
就会脸是雅光的
在买一些比较贵架的
呼吸之前最好
都买种小杨试一下
因为能费还有一些小东西
交兰的一个油
也是被博主重套到了
然后我朋友说这个油挺清爽的
这个是预见他们家的
宥布的木油
屋木松紧山桃
很好的就是那种桃子的味道
这个屋木松紧挺不错的
就是感觉东天里面会很喜欢这个味道
这是我跟大家分享的
我买的这个A9扣的交兰泡
到货了我买的是三核装
一共能到手有六核
然后我是买的两单
我之前给你们分享过的那个香港的洗发水
就我目前用到我个人
最爱的一款洗发水
就是洗完泡皮真的很舒服
这个是节毛膏和一个好像是夜体没粉
这是我被珍珠重草的
而且它的这个头非常的小巧
所以它不会占过多的料体
它这个刷头有两个方向
所以上下节毛它都很好啥
这个节毛膏真的很不错
就是我已经带装有八九个小时了吧
完全每云一点都不云
跟分明
我知道这是什么
这应该是一个口红
我在韩光找一个化妆施留化妆
它当时给我用的那个口红的颜色
特别好看
所以我就为了复刻那个口红的颜色
我现在就买了一堆腌子色的口红
看一下这也像不像
因为我觉得还可以
灰子掉的
就是很时候我们赶納皮
我还买了两支
我们一起来对比一下
买香的
这只是最便宜的
它是英雄用的好像才
二十块钱吧
这只是它是最紫的
然后这个中间是偏土色
这个是叫色
他们家新出的一个系列
三红高纯密
麦麦粉和透摩卡
找两个宝贝版
这两个我就不拆了
到时候你们自己拆
这个颜值真的做得好高啊
它这个料体是这种
非常好取的
这两支纯密
就是一个金属的一个头
而且它图上去之后
会有那种两两的感觉
水淘凍
寶导度比较高的
我个人的话
我会更喜欢这个颜色
现在上嘴来势你想看
以上嘴就是
欧美饭起来
哇这个
照露丝同款的盘子
挣了一个月
但是真的很好看
平时就能放一些水果什么的
用这个盘子吃饭的时候感觉心情很愿意
这也是我买一个养生虎
眼睛很高耶
妈也超爱买几个
然后她知道我买了个养生虎
然后我就快地又带着没拆
她就天天吹我说
你什么时候可以拆没有快点
我好像看你的养生虎
像什么样子
她是这样子的
这个养生虎
我又有一段时间给你们分享
好不好我用买
真夕的植发器
她这个地方是加水进去的
如果好用我后续给大家分享吧
这是一个植发书
最近就是为了我的这个发型
操作的行买了一规的工具
再加点钱的
差伸文句多
这两方桌子是一样的
然后我就是家里面一双
过多试一双
我现在脚上穿的还是这一双
这个是我买的韩国的那个冤车水
这是我上一次去韩国发现的最惊喜的一个东西
因为我是那种冤车非常非常严重的人
大概二十分钟的车程
我都能图的那种马上
我不是要去长白山了嘛
所以连我就团了二十屏
她里面是这个样子的
就是一屏一屏的
做车前半个小时
喝这一屏
然后基本上我不想吃
都不会云车
我很深刻已经没有来我的相影经
全部的拆完了
这期大家看得上不上呢
上的话记得给我一个
你们懂的